This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon footprint.
You can also sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your carbon footprint or support
rainforest protection projects.
Blepharisma have appeared on our channel several
times before.
In fact, this channel got its start thanks
to a video that James, our master of microscopes,
once posted of a Blepharisma dying.
Around 3 million people watched that video,
including me, your host Hank Green.
So if you enjoy this channel, you can thank
that dead Blepharisma.
But perhaps you should wait for another day
to thank them.
Because in about 10 seconds, you’re going
to watch a Blepharisma explode.
Here it is, glowing with autofluorescence
underneath UV light.
You can see its oblong shape and oral groove
outlined in red…but not for long.
The red becomes brighter and brighter, but
it also looks like it’s starting to expand.
And then suddenly, the walls of the blepharisma
burst, the organism popping like a crimson balloon.
The blepharisma bubbles and pours into its
surroundings and it all happens within a matter
of seconds.
Let’s watch it again.
Dead or dying microbes are a common enough
sight in our journey through the microcosmos.
And there are many potential culprits behind
these deaths: predators, accidents, environmental
changes, the inevitable march of life into
death.
But the culprit this time… well, it was
us.
Us and the UV light that is part of our new
fluorescence microscope upgrade.
And our UV light has been very exciting for
us.
In particular, it’s allowed us to look for
methanogens, or Archaea, which sometimes take
up residence inside protists.
Under normal light, it’s hard to tell the
tiny archaea and the tiny bacteria apart.
But under UV light, the archaea will shine
blue.
So UV can reveal new aspects of the microcosmos.
But if you’ve ever fallen asleep on a beach
or just stayed out in the sun a bit too long,
you may have also experienced the darker side
of UV light.
No one wants a sunburn, but fortunately, we
have defenses, like hair, and melanin, and
sunscreen which can block or absorb UV rays
before they cause further damage in our cells.
We also, and this is crucial, have more than
one cell...so if some of them die, which when
you get a sunburn they do, the rest of our
bodies can live on.
Not all organisms have these sorts of protections.
Or if they do, they’re designed for exposure
to the sun, not the intense scrutiny of our UV light.
So when James wants to hunt Archaea, he has
to be careful.
He can quickly shine the UV light to see if
anything blue appears.
But he has to quickly shut it off.
Because as we’ve seen, even a few seconds
of exposure to the UV light will kill off
his pond buddies.
We want to note that as we said earlier, death
is a common reality of the microcosmos…we
just usually prefer to walk in on a microbe
dying rather than being the cause of death.
But for this episode, we decided to make an
exception and use our UV light for an extended
period of time, with the knowledge that it
would kill the microbe we were watching.
Because these explosions illustrate the cost
of doing business with light.
The word for this business is phototoxicity.
Death by light.
And while it can happen under other monochromatic
lights, the particular wavelength and intensity
of our UV light makes it much more harmful
to our organisms than our other red, blue,
or green light sources.
This death starts with excitation.
When the light hits the organism, it can potentially
excite chemical structures inside the cell,
sending electrons up and down, and producing
fluorescent colors in the process.
But colors aren’t the only thing that gets
created.
If there’s oxygen around, it will react
with the excited fluorescent molecule, creating
what are known as reactive oxygen species.
In biology, reactive oxygen species are byproducts
of different cellular processes that metabolize
oxygen, which can make them part of normal
life.
There are even reactive oxygen species that
are involved in signaling pathways.
But the “reactive” in their name is key
to what makes an excess amount of them dangerous.
If you are an organism, and you are, there
are a lot of reactions you want to have happen
in your cells.
You want your DNA to link together correctly,
you want your enzymes to find the right substrates.
But reactive oxygen species are happy to react
with all of those molecules too, damaging
them and getting in the way of the chemistry
that we need to survive.
What phototoxicity will look like depends
on the organism and the light being directed at it.
For the organisms we’ve been showing here,
like this homalozoon, the overall effect of
this intense UV light seems to be unanimous:
the cell swells up and bursts open, like a
galaxy erupting on our slide.
But while the overall effect is the same,
the internal machinations are likely different,
triggered by a complex interplay of different
chemicals that nonetheless react to our light
source in a similar, catastrophic fashion.
While we’re not sure of the culprits behind
the homalozoon’s death, we can identify
one of the chemicals that likely sets off
the blepharisma’s death.
It’s the reddish pigment molecule called
blepharismin that gives the ciliate its color
under more normal circumstances.
Outside of the UV light, you can see the membrane-bound
pigments neatly distributed along the rows
that stretch from one end of the blepharisma
to the other.
But under our UV light and with oxygen in
the environment, the blepharismin reacts to
form reactive oxygen species, and death follows
quickly from there.
But while toxic in our experiment, we should
note that the blepharismin serves a key purpose
for the blepharisma: defense.
These pigment molecules are toxic to some
of Blepharisma’s predators in both the light and the dark.
That makes the pigment somewhat like UV light:
necessary for survival, yet also a delicate negotiation.
But in the same way that we manage our relationship
with the sun, scientists have learned ways
to manage these phototoxic reactions.
They’ve had to in order to understand how
we can use fluorescence microscopy to study
cells and organisms.
They’ve learned how to modulate wavelength
and intensity and duration, along with many
other factors, to wield light in a way that
better serves their purposes.
In the case of the blepharisma, for example,
scientists found that using a moderate light
for around 1 hour wasn’t much of a problem
for them.
But with more time under the light, the cells
would eventually die.
It’s easy to think of the microcosmos as
a separate world from us, even when we know
that the microscope is a bridge between large
and small.
But these deaths at the hand of our supposed
bridge are a cautionary sign that we are encountering
microbes in a world that is both natural and
manufactured at the same time.
The way that we light that world impacts the
way we see the organisms, and it also shapes
their lives—reminding us that they are stronger
often than we can fathom, but fragile nonetheless.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for supporting
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Wren is a place where you can calculate your
carbon footprint, then offset it by funding
projects that plant trees and protect rainforests.
We’re gonna need a lot of different approaches
to stop the climate crisis, and this is one
way that you can learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action.
I took their climate quiz, answering a few
questions about my lifestyle so that I could
see what my carbon footprint was.
Then, they should be some ways I could start
reducing it.
But no one can reduce their carbon footprint
to zero.
So, by using Wren, I was able to offset what
I had left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive updates
from the tree planting, rainforest protection,
and other projects you support.
And also we have partnered with Wren to plant
10 extra trees for the first 100 people to
sign up using the link in the description!
The people on the screen right now, those
are our Patreon patrons.
They’re the people who support this channel
every single episode so that we can continue
diving into this wonderful and mysterious
world.
So, if you love what we do here, these are
some of the people to thank.
And if you want to become one of those people,
all you got to do is go to Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, and why wouldn’t
you, you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.